et has obtained never-before-seen text  messages allegedly between Amber Heard  and her estranged husband Johnny Depp's  purported assistant and the conversation  is shocking it's amber allegedly talking  with Steven deters the actors one-time  assistant  we're told the conversation is from May  of 2014 a few months after Depp and  heard got engaged  amber appears to be discussing alleged  abuse by Depp Steven purportedly writes  when I told him he kicked you he cried  the actress says obviously he has no  idea what he did or to the extent he did  it in court filings Hurd has accused the  actor of abusing her throughout their  relationship and of having substance  abuse issues  Steven allegedly writes the actor quote  knows he has done wrong he wants to get  better now amber laments he's done this  many times before and I always stay  heard filed for divorce on May 25th